فعلا ثمان اشخاص فقط يمتلكون ثروات تعادل
ما يملكه حوالي ثلاثه مليارات 600 مليون
نسمه يمثلون النصف الافقر من سكان العالم
خلاصه تقرير نشرته منظمه اوكسفام الدوليه
المعنيه بمحاربه الفقر تحذر فيه من ان
الهوه الكبيره بين الفقراء والاغنياء
تتوسع بشكل مضطرد وان كبار الاثرياء
يعمقها باساليب ملتويه ويراكم اموالهم
باساليب اكثر التواء منها التهرب من سدد
الضرائب المستحقه عليهم وخفض اجور العمال
في شركاتهم واستغلال نفوذهم للتاثير على
القرارات الحكوميه لمصالحهم في ظل غياب اي
دور تعديلي لحكومات الدول لوقف اختلال
توزيع الثروات لتكون اكثر عدلا وانسانيه
تقرير ناصر ايه
الطاهر فلينتبه العالم الفجوه بين
الاغنياء والفقراء في تعاظم مقلق تقرير
منظمه اوكسفام السنوي يحدثنا عن ثمانيه
اشخاص تعادل ثروتهم ما تملكه نصف البشريه
انه النصف الافقر من عالمنا وتستند حسابات
المنظمه البريطانيه غير الحكوميه الى
بيانات بنك كريدي سويس السويسري ومجله
فوربس الامريكيه اما الاثرياء الثمانيه
المشار اليهم فلاف ان سته منهم
امريكيون ستجد واجهه لثراء هؤلاء اما
امبراطوريه برمجيات او شركات استثمار او
سلسله متاجر ازياء او موقع تجاره الرونيه
او موقع تواصل اجتماعي او مؤسسه اعلاميه
انه الثراء هنا في ازدياد بينما هناك تظهر
بيانات توزيع الدخل ان ثروات النصف الافقر
من سكان العالم في تراجع ليس هذا اول
تقرير من نوعه تعده اوكسفام قالت في تقرير
العام الماضي ان اغنى 62 شخصا في العالم
يمتلكون ثروه تعادل ما يملكه نصف افقر
سكان العالم وذاك رقم ضاء لهذا العام بشكل
كبير بسبب توافر ما تقول المنظمه انها
بيانات اكثر دقه بدقه ايضا تعدد اوكسفام
طرقا يعمق بها كبار الاثرياء الفجوه مع
عالم الفقراء تشير الى التهرب من سداد
الضرائب المستحقه عليهم وشركاتهم وخفض
اجور العمال وزياده عائدات المساهمين الى
حدها الاقصى وكذا استغلال النفوذ في
التاثير على القرارات الحكوميه لصالحهم
لم يكن صدفه ان نشر تقرير اوكسفام بينما
يجتمع صناع القرار وعدد من اثرى اثرياء
العالم في منتجع دافوس السويسري الشتوي
كانما هي رساله الى المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي فالمنظمات بالعمل على تقليص دخل
اولئك الذين يتصدرون قائمه اثرياء العالم
كما طالبت بكبح التهرب الضريبي بل بالتحول
بعيدا عما دعتها راسماليه التي تح
بالاثرياء بشكل غير متناسب والانتقال الى
اقتصاد اكثر تركيزا على الشان
الانساني المراد اذا تغييرات جذريه في
طريقه اداره الاقتصاد العالمي حتى لا تكون
فوائده حكرا على ما تصفها اوكسفام بالقله
المؤثره صاحبه النفوذ كلام قد يروق
للفقراء لكن نقادا استغرب انشغال مؤسسه
تعنى بمكافحه الفقر على نحو غريب
بالاغنياء و احصاء ثروتهم فما يتوجب على
اوكسفام فعله برايهم هو التركيز على وسائل
دعم النمو الاقتصادي وذاك تحديدا ما تعتقد
المنظمه انها تفعله فحسب تقاريرها كما يرى
مسؤولها انها تتحدى النخب السياسيه
والاقتصاديه من مثيلات تلك المجتمعه في
دافوس انها تعري وضعا تصفه بالفاضي فاقم
اللام مساواه اما تغيير ذاك الوضع فساله
اخرى
نبدا النقاش مع ضيفين في هذه الحلقه من
لندن ماكس لوسن رئيس حمله اللام مساواه في
منظمه اوكسفام ومن باريس كميل الساري
استاذ الاقتصاد في جامعه السوربون اهلا
بكما سيد ماكس لوسن لو بدات معك لطالما
عاش العالم في ظل هذه الثنائيه والتفاوت
في توزيع الثروات ما الذي كشفه برايكم
الجديد الذي كشفه هذا
التقرير
اعتقد ان ما هو واضح هو رغم ان عدم
التساوي دائما كان موجودا وكانت هناك فجوه
بين الاغنياء والفقراء نرى الان فجوه
هائله بين اغنى الاغنياء وبين الفقراء هذه
ظاهره جديده لم نرى مثل هذه الفجوه منذ
نحو 100 عام
وهي تضر
بمجتمعاتنا واقتصاديات وسياساتنا انها
ازمه وهو امر لا ينبغي ان نقبله ونعيش معه
انه من صلع الانسان ويمكن ان يعالج من قبل
الانساني ايض كميل الساري فجوه كبيره لم
لم يشهدها العالم منذ 100
عام ما الاسباب الكامله وراء هذه الفجوه
وتوسعها برايكم علما انه اذا يعني هذا
التقرير يكشف نهايه السباق اذا ما بدانا
ببدايه السباق الكل متساوي في في الفرص
لماذا هذه الفجوه الكبيره
برايكم
نعم وكانت هناك تحولات
منذ بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه كان
التيار الكينزي اي
انه يعتمد
على الطلب
وتوطيد الدخل وكذلك الرفع من الاجور لكي
ترفع نسبه الاستهلاك وكذلك لكي يكون هناك
مبيعات كبرى للشركات فهذا المنطق المنطق
الكينزي الذي كان يعتمد على فصل الارباح
عن الاجور لصالح الاجور ولتحفيز النمو
الاقتصادي كان مربحا لكل الاطراف للشركات
وكذلك ل العمال ولكن ازمه السبعينات التي
ليست هي ازمه ارتفاع النفط لان هناك يعني
عده مغالطات في هذا الموضوع ازمه
السبعينات في الدول الكبرى الدول الصناعيه
هي ازمه هيكليه ازمه الاستثمارات ازمه
الربحيه فمنذ ذلك بدا هذا التحول الذي
يقول ان هذه السياسه الكنزيه فشلت والان
يجب التوجه
لسياسه العرض اي ان تقويه ارباح الشركات
وكانت هناك يعني هذه النظره
الاقتصاديه المدعمه من طرب فريدمان ومدرسه
شيكاجو يعني
جسدها السيد ريجان في الولايات المتحده
والسيده مارجريت تيتشر في بريطانيا وتحررت
كل القيود على الراسمال وعلى التحركات
الماليه والبورصات والاسواق الماليه حررت
من كل القيود ولذلك هذه هذه الاستثمارات
في البرسات
وفي يعني كل حتى المواد الاوليه يعني
المواد الاوليه بما فيها النفط هي عرضه و
لهذه المضاربات وترفعها
وتخفضها
يعني صناديق التحو الى اخره فكل هذه
التحولات جعلت انتصار ل للارباح على حساب
الاجور وراينا تفقير كبير حتى في الدول
الكبرى يجب العلم ان في الولايات المتحده
الفقراء هم اكثر مما عليه بالنسبه مثلا
للصين وهذا لا يتكلم عليه احد وهذه النخبه
يعني انتصار الماليه العالميه اضرت كثير
بالاقتصاديات
الكبرا 2008 يؤدي ثمنها الكل جيد كميل
الساري قبل ان اتابع تعالوا نتعرف على
الاغنياء الثمانيه تقرير منظمه اوكسفام
الذي استند لمعطيات نشرتها مجله فوربس
المختصه في شؤون الثروه والاثرياء عبر
العالم استعرض قائمه الثمانيه الاكثر ثراء
على وجه الكله الارضيه وهم على التوالي
بيل جيتس مؤسس امبراطوريه البرمجيات
الامريكيه العملاقه مايكروسوفت تقدر ثروته
بحوالي 55 مليار دولار الاسباني ام ناسيو
اورتيجا مؤسس شركه اندي تكس التي تمتلك
سلسله متاجر زاره تقدر ثروته بحوالي 67
مليار دولار ورن بفت تقدر ثروته بحوالي 60
مليار و800 مليون دولار الملياردير
المكسيكي ذو الاصول لانيه كارلوس سليم حلو
صاحب مجموعه شركه جروبو كارسو تقدر ثروته
ب 50 مليار دولار جيف بيسو مؤسس موقع
التجاره الالكتروني الشهير امازون بثروه
تقدر ب 45 مليار و2 مليون دولار اما مارك
زوكربرغ مؤسس ورئيس موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الاشهر فيسبوك تقدر ثروته ب 44
مليار و600 مليون دولار لاري السون الشريك
المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي لشركه البرمجيات
الامريكيه اوراكل تقدر ثروته ب 43 و600
مليون دولار واخيرا مايكل بلومبرج مؤسس
ورئيس مؤسسه بلومبرج الاعلاميه الامريكيه
وتقدر ثروته ب 40 مليار دولار ماكس لوسن
ثمانيه مقابل نصف عدد البشريه هل هل كان
يمكن لهذه المعادله ان تكون اكثر عدلا مما
هي عليه يعني لماذا لم يوثق لم يوسع
التقرير دائره الاغنياء كما فعل مع دائره
الفقراء مثلا هل هناك حكمه خلف هذا الامر
خصوصا وان التقرير يتزامن مع عقد
دافوس نعم ان ما نحاول البرهنه عليه من
خلال تقريرنا هو وجود هذا الفارق الكبير
بين ثمانيه رجال هم الاغنى في العالم ونصف
البشريه هذا لا منطقي ابدا بان يمتلك
تمتلك هذه الحفنه القليله من البشر كل هذا
المال في ايديها اما كل هذا العدد نصف
البشريه لا يمتلكون شيئا هذا يعني انهم
هؤلاء الاغنياء يمتلكون من المال ما قد
ينفقونه اذا ما احتاجوا لالف عمر وعمر ولن
ينفذ هذا المال لا يحتاجونه ينفقونه على
اليخوت الفارهه وغيرها بامكانهم ان يعيشوا
بطريقه اكثر عدلا كميل الساري ذكرت قبل
قليل مقاربه ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين مثلا سته من اصل ثمانيه
اغنياء العالم هم امريكيون يعني حتى هنا
لا يوجد مساواه ما دلالات هذا
برايك نعم الولايات المتحده يعني عرفت
تقدم كبير واستفادت من العولمه واستفادت
كذلك من هيمنتها على كل المؤسسات الدوليه
صندوق النقد الدولي البنك الدولي
وخصوصا اعتبار ان الدولار اصبح عمله
عالميه فرضت على العالم باسره وهذا
اتفاقيه بروتن وودز والاسواق الماليه
الامريكيه هي التي تسيطر وفي شيكاجو تحدد
كل اسعار المواد الاوليه يجب هناك مشكل
كبير
في النظام السياسي الامريكي هو من البلدان
القليله في العالم التي الاحزاب الكبرى
الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون من من يمولهم
الشركات الكبرى بالمليارات فهذا ممنوع في
كل الدول مثلا الاوروبيه ولكن مباع في
الولايات المتحده وهؤلاء الشركات عندهم
تاثير على على الرئيس الجديد المنتخب
كيفما كان نوعه
ويفرض عليه ضمنيا وحتى بشكل
صريح يعني حمايه رؤوس الاموال
حمايه الجنات الضريبيه واقامه تشريعات
مباحه السيد ترامب قال بانه سيحرر من جديد
يعني الاسواق الماليه بعد ان الاواق يعني
عرفت انتكاسات وعممت الازمه على العالم
منذ
2008 و حتى قانون دود فرانك الذي صوتت
عليه يعني الكونغريس
والمجلس الشيوخ بقياده الرئيس اوباما حتى
هذا الذي فرض بعض القواعد والقوانين على
هذه المؤسسات الماليه البنكيه الكبرى
ستمحى من
الوجود بعد انتخاب سي طرب هذا ما قال بعد
انتخابه ساعود اليك بسؤال اخير ولكن اسال
ماكس لوسن سيد لوسن هل لديكم فكره عن
الوطن العربي ما حجم الهوه بين اغنياه
وفقرائهم مثلا باقتضاب لو
سمحت البيانات المتوفره عن العالم العربي
بيانات فقيره للغايه لكن هناك مؤشرات تدل
على ان الفارق بين الاغنياء والفقراء كبير
تزايد في عدد كبير من بلدان العالم العربي
الامر ليس واضحا لا ندري كم هي اقيام
الثروات التي يمتلكها هؤلاء الاغنياء لكن
هناك زياده في عدم التساوي وهذا جزء وسبب
من اسباب عدم الاستقرار في المنطقه لان
هناك كثيرون يشعرون بان النظام الاقتصادي
قد تخلى عنهم وتركهم كميل الساري التقرير
دعا الى التغير
الجذري في الاقتصاد العالمي اي خطوات
ترونها مناسبه والاكثر واقعيه للتطبيق
لردم هذه الهوه بين الفقراء والاغنياء
نعم انا احضر كتاب وكتبت كذلك من قبل عبر
مقالات على ضروره ضروره هذا هذه الشراكه
بين دول المشرق ما اسميه دول المشرق بما
فيها دول الخليج بثرواتها للاستثمار في
الدول الافريقيه وخصوصا شمال افريقيا
بالتكنولوجيا الاوروبيه تحديدا
والعالميه وعبر
اتفاقيات الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يمكن ان
يخرج من الازمه الا بتعاون مع الدول دول
الجنوب ودول الجنوب هي مستقبل الدول
الاوروبيه اذا الولايات المتحده يعني لم
تود هذه السياسه التعاون
بسياسه حمائه جديده فيجب التركيز على
الشراكه شراكه مربحه للجميع وليست فقط
يعني هديه او هبه ولكن استثمارات للمستقبل
وفي المستقبل وكذلك في ميدان الفلاحه في
ميدان مثلا التكنولوجيا الرفيعه هناك يعني
عديد من الموارد البشريه توجد في دول
المغرب الكبير وكذلك في شب افريقيا يجب
توظيفها بالتعامل مع دول الجنوب وكذلك
بتوظيف رؤوس اموال تاتي من الخليج واعاده
تصنيع كذلك وتعددت الصناعات في دول الخليج
بنفسها شكرا لك كميل الساري استاذ
الاقتصاد في جامعه السوربون في باريس
واشكر في لندن ماكس لوسن رئيس حمله اللام
مساواه في منظمه اوكسفام